bonsoir merci à nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal
on commence vite et avec les titres de
votre actualité locale à montigny le
bretonneux semaine de sensibilisation
aux différents handicaps nous en
parlerons avec marie noëlle tarot
adjointe à la solidarité à l'action
sociale également en plateau
la présidente de france alzheimer il
l'ine le président dans le département
de l'association française pour la
recherche sur la trisomie 21
les élus de la majorité à guyancourt se
mobilisent contre une éventuelle
fermeture de la pmi le conseil
départemental entend optimiser les
moyens en fusionnant plusieurs de ces
structures
enfin ce week-end se déroule le
traditionnel festival de bande dessinée
de but que de nombreux auteurs invités
et notamment et rock libinois est
l'auteur des profs série populaire
adapté depuis au cinéma et pour ouvrir
cette édition du lundi 5 octobre nous
allons parler mobilisation une vingtaine
de médecins libéraux a manifesté ce
lundi à la gare de versailles chantiers
contre le projet de loi de la ministre
marisol touraine
les médecins se disent aujourd'hui
menacée par la volonté de généraliser le
tiers payant
selon eux le projet de loi de leurs
ministres sous tutelle les obligera à
prescrire ou non certains médicaments
dans les semaines à venir ils ont prévu
d'autres manifestations cet après midi
c'était devant le sénat à paris qu'ils
ont crié leur colère nous y reviendrons
dans les prochaines semaines
enfin les motards évinois également en
colère samedi ils étaient une centaine à
manifester dans le département contre
les mesures prises par la mairie de
paris notamment l'interdiction pour les
véhicules antérieurs à 2002 circuler
dans les rues de la capitale et
l'abaissement de la vitesse
parti de saint germain en laye à l'appel
de la fédération française des motards
en colère des yvelines ils n'ont rallié
versailles à vitesse réduite
on écoute tout de suite jean leprovost
coordinateur de l'association pour les
élèves
on a des interdictions qui risque de
s'amplifier
et qui ne correspond pas à une réalité
de terrain sachant que ces décisions
sont prises par des écologistes qui
prennent pour prétexte la pollution pour
interdire un certain nombre de choses
ce qu'on demande nous c'est que ces
problèmes de déplacement et pollution
soit prêt au niveau régional ou dans
lequel nous pouvons influer puisque nous
sommes électeurs ce qui n'est pas le cas
sur paris et ça ça n'est pas supportable
et je vous disais en titre aujourd'hui
commence la 12e édition de la semaine du
handicap à montigny le bretonneux pour
en parler avec nous ce soir
rolande homme automne présidente de
france alzheimer yvelines marie noëlle
tard au maire adjointe déléguée à la
solidarité et à l'action sociale de
montigny-le-bretonneux et christian le
poc président de l'antenne
départementale de l'association
française pour la trisomie 21
merci à vous trois d'être venu sur notre
plateau différents événements initiative
et ateliers de sensibilisation sont
organisées donc cette semaine dans le
cadre justement handicap
aujourd'hui l'association valentin haüy
a animé un atelier de sensibilisation
sur la malvoyance au relais des seniors
de montigny le bretonneux
je vous propose de regarder ce sujet
réalisé par fanny bourdon dans le cadre
de la semaine du handicap l'association
valentin et hui s'est rendu au relais
des seigneurs de montigny pour
sensibiliser leurs résidents à la
malvoyance
l'association aide les mâles et les non
voyants à sortir de leur isolement et
gagner en autonomie
après avoir pris leur dessert les yeux
bandés les seniors du centre ont suivi
un parcours particulier on a préparé un
parcours à la can qui va évoluer qui va
se dérouler ensuite on leur mettant un
bandeau donc sur les yeux et ça leur
permet de se rendre compte de
l'importance du débat sera la can pour
l'appréhender le l'espace et se déplacer
sans difficulté avait h a aussi pour
vocation de conseiller du matériel
spécialisé réveil stylo parlant lunettes
de simulation ou encore télé
agrandisseur c'est une tablette c'est
une loupe électronique qui a des
facultés très importante on peut grossir
l'image et on peut aussi changer les
fonds colorés
donc on a en fonction des affections
qu'on a personne on adapte en fonction
de leurs problèmes et puis on grossit
les images et ça permet de re lire
correctement sur le sur un document
en france deux millions de personnes
sont en déficience visuelle soit avec
l'un de deux yeux à moins de trois
dixièmes
parmi eux 60 mille sont aveugles ce
chiffre est malheureusement
proportionnel à l'allongement de la
durée de vie alors marié à noël tarot se
sont donc à des ateliers conciliation
qui s'organisait comme celui qu'on vient
de voir toute la semaine c'est vraiment
voilà le coeur de la semaine du handicap
ce sont ces ateliers de sensibilisation
oui en particulier bien entendu
aujourd'hui c'était avec les seniors qui
participait au relais mais c'est aussi
vis-à-vis des enfants des élèves des
écoles donc il ya vraiment tout un
travail toute la semaine de
sensibilisation aussi bien au niveau de
l'activité scolaire que au niveau des
accueils de loisirs avec lesquels nous
travaillons puisque je viens même d'être
invitée jeudi pour aller écouter une
chanson chantée en langue des signes
donc c'est vraiment ce travail là et qui
dès le départ a été la volonté de dire
que l'on voulait changer le regard sur
le handicap et faire qu'aujourd'hui les
personnes en situation de handicap et
bien puissent avoir une vie citoyenne
la meilleure pour eux en fonction de
leur handicap et que peut-être
eh bien nous les élus nous essayons de
compenser ce cette difficulté qu'ils ont
au quotidien pour être citoyen appelle à
part entière alors christian lecoq et
rampton vous organise également fan ya
des ateliers des spectacles des mêmes
des événements sportifs organisés ou de
fond de cette semaine vous organisez
donc un une soirée buffet spectacle donc
frt 118 et france alzheimer à la salle
paul gauguin à montigny le bretonneux
ce que vous nous expliquer un peu le but
soit là pour que cette association et
quel est le but un peu l'aide à la visée
le but c'est de récolter des fonds pour
la recherche et surtout là
nous avons invité le professeur madame
londons qui va nous parler des
recherches qui sont faites en ce moment
sur la maladie d'alzheimer et la
trisomie 21 il y aurait un rapprochement
voilà alors justement cette association
c'est parce que voilà il ya vraiment une
corrélation entre ces deux maladies peut
être tout à fait alors pour la la ferté
78 il ya eu un communiqué qui a été fait
à rouen en 2006 et donc il ya un lien
entre ces deux pathologies et donc on en
saura certainement plus à ce dîner
samedi c'est vraiment pour récolter des
foins pour la recherche la recherche
sémantique est également voilà deux sont
récoltés c'est un problème qu'il
faudrait tout remettre sur le devant de
la scène la recherche de fonds pour les
maladies pour les environs du cap alors
nous notre association n'est pas
vraiment pour faire l'école à récolter
des fonds pour la recherche
puisqu'on à l'union nationale à paris
qui s'en charge mais effectivement on a
très souvent de temps en temps des
personnes qui nous font des dons pour la
recherche et nous les envoyons
directement bien entendu pour la
recherche mais c'est vrai que c'est
assez difficile et plus la recherche
s'avancera aimé ça sera pour nos
associations c'est sur wii
et nous donc au niveau avec fierté 78
qui a été créée donc en 2014
on a envoyé un courrier à toutes les
communes du département 78 sur les 262
communes
on a une cinquantaine qui nous ont reçus
et on a déjà des demandes de subventions
pour 2016 je les bombes
parce que votre association est très
jeune elle s'est créée enfin dans les
yvelines en 2014 en 2014 fiat alors que
la ferté existe depuis 25 ans il ya
justement cet effet spectacle il ya
beaucoup de d'événements aussi autour du
sport de la culture c'est voilà une
façon de parler du handicap de façon
différente voilà c'est une façon
différente et puis surtout ce que l'on
essaye que ce soit dans les activités
que nous allons développer là c'est
aussi de faire participer et donc
effectivement dans les actions que nous
avons et puis les réussites que l'on
considère avoir pu mettre en place il ya
par exemple samedi nous aurons le
tournoi de hand fauteuil nous avons
commencé tout petit et puis aujourd'hui
il ya des équipes qui viennent même de
province pour faire ce cette compétition
ce tournoi nous avons également tout ce
qui se fait au niveau des scolaires nous
avons aussi des conférences
d'information et ses dossiers pour faire
parler un petit peu les personnes qui
vivent au quotidien on a aussi un petit
spectacle qui va avoir lieu pour les
enfants très jeunes
le petit chaperon rouge en langue des
signes donc nous avons aussi le handi
recrutement pour permettre aux personnes
handicapées de rencontrer éventuellement
de futurs employeurs et de voir s'il ya
une possibilité est bien pour eux de
trouver une activité salariée comme
comme les autres personnes justement
c'est la douzième édition que ça fait 12
ans que saint louis est ce que vous avez
eu des choses qui ont changé
concrètement peut-être j'imagine des
commerçants qui ont peut-être pris
conscience l'association des personnes
en situation de handicap pour améliorer
l'accessibilité à leurs magasins
alors c'est vrai que malgré tout de
toute façon il ya eu quand même la loi
de 2005 qui a remis à neuf un petit peu
la loi de 75 qui avait déjà de bonnes
choses mais qui a été un petit peu au
pied c'est vrai que la loi de 2005 aussi
énormément 2015 tout devait être
accessible
on n'y est pas encore mais il ya quand
même de gros efforts qui ont été faits
au début nous avions essayé de faire
comprendre d'aller voir rencontrer les
commerçants pour leur expliquer que
peut-être de déplacer un petit peu une
étagère ou quelque chose permettait à
une personne à mobilité réduite c'est
aussi d'avoir toutes ces bandes
podotactiles qu'on peut retrouver sur la
ville pour les personnes non voyantes
donc on essaye petit à petit bon il ya
une commission d'accessibilité qui est
assez
disons active au niveau de la ville il y
en a une autre aussi au niveau de la
communauté d'agglomération dont il ya
vraiment un travail qui se fait de
partenariat on va pas arrêter une un
cheminement parce que on au quai de
montigny et qu'on va sur voisins ou sur
guyancourt donc on essaye au contraire
de pouvoir faire que les cheminements à
l'intérieur de la ville puisse se faire
le mieux possible
donc c'est également une symbolique pour
mettre en lumière votre activité que
vous faites au quotidien finalement
toute l'année est ce que par exemple
j'imagine de rom automne vous avez aussi
à la sensation qu'il faut vraiment
mettre l'accent sur ce que vous faites
flâner parce qu'on ne parle pas assez
par exemple de la maladie d'alzheimer
oui on parle pas assez de la maladie
d'alzheimer
on en parle quand même plus que voilà
mais les personnes ont beaucoup de mal à
venir nous contacter à venir prendre des
renseignements chez nous alors qu'on
peut leur apporter quand même beaucoup
de choses on à la formation des aidants
quelque chose de très très important qui
est ouvert à toute personne tout étant
on n'a pas besoin d'être adhérent à
notre association
et ça c'est quelque chose de très
important parce que ça aide beaucoup les
cédants christian la fois que vous
également peut-être que c'est enfin
cette semaine handicap s'adresse voilà
tout le monde au sens position mais
peut-être aux familles qui eux aussi ne
sont pas parfois si bien informé qu'on
pourrait le penser
oui parce que on a depuis avril on
reçoit on peut recevoir des personnes
concernées par la maladie ou qui veulent
s'informer sur ces maladies est donc le
deuxième mercredi de chaque mois de 10
heures à 12 heures on a une permanence
dans notre local qui a été fourni par
les a été fourni par la mairie et donc à
aujourd'hui on encore vu personne lui
c'est un peu
notre regret parce que on sait quand
même qu'il ya même dans le 78 il ya des
personnes qui sont concernées
oui je pense que c'est comme je dis
c'est un petit pas plus un petit peu
plus un petit pas donc c'est vrai qu
effectivement la semaine du handicap
maintenant elle est connue et ce qu'on
essaye c'est qu'au quotidien tous les
jours et bien on ne remettent pas de
côté ou le range dans un placard et puis
order sortira l'année prochaine au nom
de notre objectif c'est vraiment qu'au
quotidien
eh bien nous puissions accompagner et
aider les familles comme le peuvent le
faire toutes les associations je crois
que comme je dis souvent si les
associations s'arrêtait je pense que la
france s'arrêterait aussi alors c'est un
grand merci qu on leur dit bien sûr
temps en temps ils nous sollicitent et
nous il nous pousse un petit peu nous
les élus en nous disant il faut faut
faire faut y aller quoi et tout est donc
ben c'est un grand merci que jeunes à
toutes les associations telles qu'elles
soient aujourd'hui nous avons deux
associations mais quand nous travaillons
comme nous faisons cette semaine du
handicap ce sont avec des associations
qui nous accompagnent qui nous aide que
ce soit l'unafam la paix il enfin je
vais pas toutes les citer bien entendu
mais c'est vrai que c'est quand même
quelque chose qui nous aide qui nous
accompagnent et je crois que c'est quand
même au quotidien sur montigny au moins
je pense qu'au quotidien où vivent
plutôt mieux je vais pas dire bien
commun plutôt mieux son handicap que
peut-être hélas dans d'autres villes où
ces quelques fois plus difficile
5 vous annoncions il ya beaucoup de
choses qui sont faits ce qui a encore
des gros seins des axes peut être des
points à améliorer peut-être la
communication justement entre
différentes associations les faire se
rassembler on essaye justement le
dimanche c'est un petit peu la journée
où toutes les associations se retrouvent
peuvent peuvent échanger peuvent
discuter il ya c'est comme ça que petit
à petit il ya des liens qui se disent
des actions qui se développe donc je
crois que ça c'est quand même quelque
chose d'important et ça avance mais
c'est vrai que chaque association avec
les spécificités du handicap et bien
effectivement elles sont dans dans leur
sphère par rapport à cette spécificité
et c'est peut-être à nous effectivement
justement de mettre ce lien est de
permettre les échanges donc c'est
vraiment notre objectif c'est de pouvoir
aussi accompagner les enfants avec les
crises que nous avons
sur la ville donc c'est vraiment un
travail de toute une équipe
des associations de l'équipe municipale
et puis c'est comme ça que nous arrivons
petit à petit à faire avancer le nom pas
le handicap mais avancer la connaissance
sur le handicap et faire que quand on
rencontre une personne handicapée rosie
pas systématiquement voilà là le pauvre
mais non mais il peut faire ou elle peut
faire des choses elle peut elle peut
danser elle peut chanter elle peut faire
du sport elle peut il ya les jeux
paralympiques ou un bel exemple à
montigny avec régis harel s'est on a de
la chance aussi
c'est ça aussi la vie de montigny mais
je crois que c'est ça c'est de c'est
pour ça quand je dis changer le regard
c'est dire le handicap c'est vrai que
c'est une difficulté mais on est
peut-être tous deux futurs handicapés où
on a peut-être tout chacun petit
handicap qu'on voit pas et qu'on essaye
de surmonter tous les jours donc notre
objectif il est là simplement
et oui cette semaine donc du handicap
concerne tout le monde à montigny le
bretonneux je le rappelle il ya donc du
sport des conférences des débats des
ateliers et à des spectacles au
programme de cette semaine si vous
souhaitez plus de renseignements
n'hésitez pas à aller sur le site
internet de la mairie www.montignac.com
18 points à faire merci à vous trois
d'être venu sur notre plateau nous
aurons l'occasion de reparler de cette
semaine du handicap
justement cette semaine et c'est une
malle liste maladie pardon souvent
méconnus pourtant la dyspraxie
l'altération de la capacité à exécuter
des mouvements de manière automatique
est une pathologie lourde à samedi matin
l'inspection académique de guyancourt
avec la mairie de magny les hameaux ont
organisé à la maison de l'environnement
une conférence sur les troubles de cette
maladie en moyenne 1 enfants par classe
seraient concernés par la dyspraxie
cette rencontre destinée aux enseignants
leur permettrait d'en apprendre plus sur
ce handicap difficile à dépister écoutez
les précisions recueillies au micro de
william l la dyspraxie
et en ont que peu de gens connaissent
pourtant c'est aussi fréquente la
dyslexie et donc c'est une difficulté à
coordonner les gestes du quotidien et en
particulier une difficulté avec
l'écriture du script
donc l'idée c'est d'essayer de
contourner la difficulté d'outils en
leur permettant de travailler à
l'ordinateur ou à l'oral pour leur
donner la possibilité de faire la preuve
de leur compétence scolaire
j'en ai eu l'année dernière le fait que
les enfants ne puissent pas faire une
double tâche en même temps enfin c'est
vraiment important d'en avoir conscience
et on a besoin de ce long temps de
répéter
parce que c'est une conscience qu'on
doit avoir tous les jours et nous
restons sur le social et la santé
guyancourt se bat pour ça pmi samedi
matin un rassemblement était organisé à
hull en cours devant le centre de
protection maternelle et infantile
louis pasteur une mobilisation contre la
fermeture hypothétique du centre une
centaine de personnes étaient présentes
également parmi elles de nombreux élus
venus soutenir le mouvement regardez ce
reportage signé william l c'est que les
garanties pour le maintien de la paix a
mis depuis en cours le service de
proximité risquerait de fermer sur
décision du conseil départemental
pour protester les habitants et les élus
ont décidé de se rassembler samedi matin
les services rendus par la pmi doivent
rester à guyancourt une ville de 30
mille habitants une ville où nous avons
au total plus de 1250 berceau si on
compte les berceaux municipaux et les
crèches d'entreprise sans oublier aussi
les assistantes maternelles et je
rappelle que les assistantes maternelles
justement dépendent d'une pmi
délocaliser une pmi c'est une faute
irréparable rationaliser les coûts pour
le conseil départemental
aujourd'hui dans les yvelines 40 pmi
serait il menacé de fermeture en moyenne
jusqu'à présent on avait une pmi pour 23
mille habitants demain le cauchemar
c'est que ce serait une pmi pour
soixante dix mille habitants
moi personnellement je me suis déplacée
j'ai pu l être suivie par la paix ni ici
j'aurais pas pu le faire puisque j'avais
pas de voiture j'aurais pas pu peser
monfils qui avait des problèmes de poids
continuer tout bébé donc
très important pour aller au soleil
c'est compliqué pour nous deux parce que
des gens n'est pas vécu les premiers
rendez vous chez des pédiatres il faut
payer 50 euros
premier rendez vous chez le généraliste
s'est pas donnée donc la pmi un peu
c'est la proximité aussi plus de 1000
consultations par an pour 750 permanence
pour éviter la fermeture d'une pétition
circule avec déjà plus de 1500
signataires le maire de brillant qu'on
appelle déjà à une nouvelle mobilisation
prévue en novembre
cette fois ci devant le conseil
départemental avec toutes les communes
concernées
et comme chacun dit vous le savez les
temps de retrouver notre chronique
culture avec sephora namani qui ce soir
va nous présenter un portrait original
ça savoir tout à fait au surf lorraine
je vais vous présenter le portrait des
rocs gilles corre de son vrai nom
scénariste français de bande dessinée
qui résident dans les yvelines et qu'ils
seraient présents au festival de la bd
de duke les 10 et 11 octobre prochains
mais scénariste de bande dessinée qu'est
ce donc vraiment scénariste de bd quand
on est enfant ce même pas que ça existe
c'est en gros je m'explique pour un
enfant une bd s'est dessinée est une
histoire donc quand on quand j'étais
petit moi je voyais j'adorais ça je
lisais des bd et je pensais que c'était
une seule personne qui faisait les
dessins et 40 l histoire au fur et à
mesure après quand j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser vraiment la bd je me suis
rendu compte qu'effectivement ce qui
m'intéressait le plus moi dans la bd
c'était d'inventer des histoires
racontées
donc j'ai commencé comme dessinateur
mais très vite dès que j'ai pu j'ai
écrit des histoires
alors pour une biographie non exhaustive
ce serait trop long sinon et rock des
buts pour le magazine pif gadget
puis il devient journaliste pour le coi
qui dans super picsou géant et des buts
en 98 la série les profs dans le journal
de mickey avec pika au dessin publié en
album chez bamboo edition les profs une
bd qui rencontre un beau succès non je
peux pas en parler parce qu'on me l'a
conseillé
je n'ai pas encore vraiment feuilletée
c'est un prof qui me l'a conseillé parce
que ça l'est c'est ça la muse j du livre
mais les béliers jean lipa donc donc je
la connais pas je ne pense pas mais
c'est un hobby par exemple oui des profs
qui racontent leurs anecdotes sur ce
qu'il rencontre à l'école est bon c'est
maintenant pas du tout non ça nous
dessert les professeurs en général c'est
comique et à plusieurs volets oui tout à
fait c'est toujours des histoires de
profs avec leurs élèves et c'est
toujours un c'est marrant quoi alors en
2001 on lui remet au festival
d'angoulême le prix jeunesse pour son
premier album
interro surprise depuis le succès reste
au rendez vous pour cette série dans
laquelle il portraiture avec humour les
professeurs de lycée on peut d'ailleurs
se demander d'où lui vient cette idée de
chercher chercher une série de bd qui
mettrait en scène des comment dirais-je
des enfants mais qui ne doivent plus
vraiment des enfants je vais mettre en
scène des ados parce que en bd il ya
beaucoup d'enfants qui peuvent cédric
petit spirou il ya beaucoup d'enfants
dans la bd moi je voulais mettre en
scène des ados donc je me suis dit c'est
bien un lycée est un lycée par contre
les ados ne seront pas les personnages
principaux ce seront des faire valoir
des profs qui viendront l'hérault ce qui
n'avait jamais été fait en guinée en
fait alors c'est pas moi je pensais que
justement il roy qui était professeur en
fait pas du tout non pas du tout il est
réellement scénariste et lors de notre
rencontre nous expliquer qu'il s'était
mis à écrire sur les pauvres puisqu'il
avait des amis lui même professeur et il
dit les profs de toute façon ne parle
que de ça donc dans cette baiser dans
cette bd par contre pardon pas question
de tirer sur l'épreuve avec des
questions épineuses de grève ou de
vacances mais des caricatures qui les
rendent humains et attachants et mettent
en avant leur ras-le-bol de ce travail
souvent difficiles une façon de leur
rendre hommage
alors il ya beaucoup d'albums crise on
sortait combien au total alors au total
17 depuis le premier album 16 autres ont
suivi avec la parution en dernier lieu
du xviie intitulé sortie scolaire
pour l'anecdote il faut six à huit mois
pour concevoir un album et en moyenne 10
à 12 heures pour le dessinateur pour
réaliser une planche en 2011
et rock reprend également les scénarios
de cubitus aux éditions lombard et en
2013 il crie boulard qui est le cancre
de la bd les profs qui devient lui-même
le héros de sa propre série
et justement les profs ont fait aussi
l'objet d'une adaptation
cinématographique avec evans il me
semble mais je vois que vous êtes très
calé florean exactement en 2013 film qui
a connu un grand succès en salles et en
arrive la suite avec prof 2 on en
regarde un extrait on fait moins les
malins la méthode française ont évoqué
l'ambiance et les classiques de la
poésie
hothead à part otez moi je crois encore
fait du bon boulot août
oubliée la théorie ici le parle on
pratique la porte en plein
épanouissement blague
donc tu es cuit falcon nema
alors cette fois quand est ce que le
grand public pourra retrouver et rock
mots très prochainement donc comme je le
disais au festival de la bd de buc les
10 et 11 octobre au prochain festival au
cours duquel se rapprochent projeté prof
de le vendredi soir au théâtre des
arcades de buc projection à laquelle
sera présent et rock et deux jours s'en
suivront de dédicaces petits plaisirs
auxquels j ai moi même eu le droit de
goûter et je remercie encore et rock
donc les fora vous êtes chanceuse
vraiment merci pour votre chronique on
vous retrouve mercredi pour un nouveau
numéro de kiosques à 10h30 ce sera après
le jt et ses foires vous avez peut-être
participer à cet événement le très
urbain de montils bretonneux était
programmé ce dimanche au départ du
centre sportif pierre de coubertin
cette année le parcours a été modifié il
se dispute à présent sur des sentiers de
terre et sur du bitume
les courageux vous avez fait partie non
pas vous auriez dû moi aussi j'aurais dû
les courageux coureurs devaient
également monter des escaliers regarder
à ce reportage signé william el est
mickaël millero formule pour le trail de
montigny le bretonneux pour son édition
2015 la course à pied a été totalement
modifié à travers ce désormais huit
quartiers de la commune pour un parcours
total de 13 kilomètres des courants ont
pu tester leur endurance et leur
cheville sur un circuit hybride une
combinaison de routes de chemins
d'escalier et de trottoirs
cette année c'est la nouvelle version
puisque jusqu'à présent faisait une
course de 10 km
sur du bitume là c'est une première donc
il ya bien sûr il ya des habitués qui
reviennent et qui sont un petit peu
surpris mais sinon on espère créer une
nouvelle habitude pour cette nouvelle
édition l'événement a fait le plein ils
étaient 3 128 à prendre le départ de la
course
parmi les participants on pouvait
apercevoir des débutants mais également
des coureurs aguerris aux le podium je
suis quand même un temps si j'arrive à
faire 45 je serai content en fait
j'habite à me dis donc je trouve que
c'est un événement important et j'ai
envie de participer à ce type
d'événement aujourd'hui c'est de me
faire plaisir
voilà après rapport je peux faire mieux
que ça pour le trail urbain oui c'est la
première fois
en visant vise le premier ex-aequo la
course a finalement été remporté par
l'imminente un nicolas grange le coureur
a bouclé les 13 km en 45 minutes et 54
secondes g8 montini donc c'est sympa
quand même gagner chez soi c'est c'est
particulier quand même déçu et puis
voilà quoi donc c'est une première
édition en plus beau que c'est toujours
sympa de gagner la première édition
vu le succès rencontré cette année le
trail urbain de montigny-le-bretonneux
devrait être reconduit l'année prochaine
et enfin avant de refermer à cette
édition nous parlons du week end des
vendanges que la fête des vendanges ce
week end comme chaque année depuis 22
ans
l'association les amis du passé à l
encours a invité tous les curieux et
amateurs à venir récolté à la main les
raisins dont les vignes de la ferme du
mousseau
ils ont ensuite été foulée au pied par
les enfants des écoles près de 160 pieds
de vignes sont plantées chaque année ce
sont environ 200 kg de fruits qui sont
récoltées à l'arrivée ces raisins blancs
et noirs permettent à l'association de
produire un peu plus de son litre de vin
dénommé le clos du mousseau mais aussi
du jus de raisin
les deux sont à boire avec modération je
le rappelle et c'est maintenant la fin
de notre édition merci de nous avoir
suivis rester avec nous tout de suite
vous retrouver michael et demi d'euros
pour le site sport il sera notamment
question du clasico pour ma part je vous
retrouve demain à 18h en direct pour une
nouvelle édition du journal je vous
souhaite une très bonne soirée